whoa is this normal chance oh oh I  understand this haha I'm white too and  white this is not normal chess at first  it looks like I'm black but I'm white  pawns are going this way Wow  so there's a variant pack in the day on  ICC where they had this I used to play  it and I know I know the one trick which  wins in like in three moves black can't  stop meat I'm just winning in three  moves there's no way I sawed 96 GG what  a game smothered mate in three moves  I feel like this this would just be the  easiest like clickbait youtube title  smother made your opponent and three  moves with this dirty trick but okay for  people watching in the future on YouTube  this is not real chess clearly because  black promoted oh yeah  counselling rights are not not present  in the scheme is the Kings on d8 anyway  oh I'll be a very short YouTube video  hello to you too hope you enjoy that  stay tuned